nathalie commande un produit
amaigrissant soit disant révolutionnaire
sur internet n'a rien à perdre la
publions freiner c'est presque gratuit
elle ne paiera que les frais de
livraison de six dollars mais quinze
jours après son achat la compagnie
utilise 80 dollars sur sa carte de
crédit
pire encore elle découvre que chaque
mois la compagnie envol produit et lui
reprend 80 dollars sur sa carte de
crédit
que s'est-il passé ce genre de pub est
un piège gros caractères vous ne payez
que les frais de livraison mais ce tout
petit par ailleurs ici indique que pour
ne payer que c'est fait vous devez
annuler l'essai dans les 14 jours de
votre commande sans cette annulation le
produit vous sera facturé chaque mois
nathalie peut-elle s'en sortir
malheureusement elle devra payer les
sommes déjà facturé prix pour annuler ce
sera la croix et la bannière après une
interminable attente elle devra parler
en anglais seulement ou représentant de
la compagnie il lui faudra peut-être
rappeler plusieurs fois
le fin mot de l'histoire méfiez vous de
ces offres alléchantes
elles cachent souvent des contrats
piégée